LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, everybody.
Thanks for coming, and welcome
to the session on building
geo services that scale.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
I work on a lot of different
technologies at Google.
But today, I'm going to
be talking about some
of the geo service and some
of the backend services
that are available from Google.
My co speaker, Elena,
unfortunately can't be here.
We're going to be talking about
an app that we were building,
and Elena was user
zero for this app.
And unfortunately, she
didn't use it correctly.
And we'll see why that ended
up delaying her actually
being here.
[LAUGHTER]
So what we want to think about
is, say you are a business
or you're a startup, and
you want to build a new app.
And you have a lot of
requirements for this app
that you just can't
compromise on.
One of these requirements
is that you've
got business logic that's
very precious to you,
and you do not want to
distribute this business
logic in an app
where somebody could
decompile it and maybe
filter through and figure out
what you're doing.
I'll give an example.
I used to work in
financial services.
We had a number of processes
in financial services where
we would look at a company.
We would look at the
fundamentals of that company.
We'd feed them into a machine.
We'd get a value
out of that machine.
And then that value
would help us estimate,
you know, is this
company doing well,
is the share price too high,
is the share price too low.
And those analytics were
very precious to us.
And there's no way that
we would distribute them.
So it's pretty common
scenario that you
don't want to distribute
this kind of stuff in an app.
You need something on the back
that would be able to scale.
Another one that we
hear a lot at Google
is that we have a number of APIs
that require like an API key.
And that API key is
used, for example,
to monitor your
usage of it so that,
if you've got a free
limit, so that you
can go up against that.
Or if you're charged, just to
make sure that you don't get
overcharged for things
that you're using.
And, again, if your API key
gets distributed with your app,
people can decompile it and
then start using your API key.
And that's been a
little bit naughty.
So a lot of people
have requirements
around, we don't want to
distribute the API key,
so we need some kind of
server side logic for this.
So we have all of
these requirements.
And I'm thinking, when we were
putting this session together,
we were saying we
really wanted to make it
feel like it's a real business.
We're going into a new venture.
We're building something new.
And we had a number of scenarios
that we wanted to look over.
But one of the scenarios
that came up constantly
was that traffic is
always a problem.
You know, how was it getting
into Shoreline today?
Were you guys OK or did
you have a traffic jam?
AUDIENCE: A traffic jam.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A traffic jam?
Yeah?
Particularly in
Silicon Valley here,
the traffic can be really bad.
But one of the things
that we discovered
when we were doing
our research is
that nothing can ruin your
day like a traffic jam caused
by a zombie invasion.
[LAUGHTER]
So we said, OK, what
if we built an app that
would help people not get
stuck in traffic jams caused
by zombie invasions.
Or if you had to
go on that route,
that you could pack the
appropriate material,
like the odd shotgun or two
or those kind of things.
So we said, what if we built
an app where people could then,
if you see a zombie invasion or
if you see zombies on the road,
that you can report
these zombies,
these could get
fed into a system.
And then when you're
using our app--
this is our wonderful billion
dollar idea app-- when you're
using this thing,
you can say, hey,
right now I'm going
to travel from here
to a particular address.
Let me check if there's
a delay on the way.
And if there's a
delay on the way,
then maybe I should go take a
look at the database of zombie
recordings just to make sure
that I need to pack a shotgun
or I need to pack whatever
it is to help me get away
from the zombies or get
around these zombies.
And then we also
said, you know what?
If you're going
to be doing that,
we also need to attribute
it a little bit.
So let's have people
report something,
but let them attribute.
So maybe it could be
two or three zombies,
or maybe it could
be 100 zombies,
or maybe the
zombies are breaking
out into a Michael Jackson
dance party-- you know,
any of these things.
So all of this
kind of information
we need to be able to capture
and to be able to store.
Oh, and then the
other thing is we
decided to get a
focus group together
to help us figure out a
name for the application.
And we spent months and months
and months and lots of people
in the focus group.
And they told us we should
call it Zombie Maps.
Go figure.
But seriously, I mean,
it's a little bit
of a flippant
scenario, but when you
think about when you're
building an app like this one,
you'll generally have an
architecture something
like this.
The heart of your business,
your business logic,
your analytics in my
financial services example,
are this service box
right in the middle.
And this service box might have
to consume third party data.
So in the example
I'm showing here,
we're consuming geo
data from Google.
But in the financial
services example,
you might be consuming financial
information from stock markets,
all those kind of things.
So your service has a
lot of smarts in there,
has analytics, has
your business logic.
If you've got API
keys, if you've
got any of that kind of stuff,
you would put it in there.
And then, like the box at
the top, the Google Maps box,
is this third party stuff
that we're consuming.
But then you'd also might
want to wrap that service
with some kind of an API level.
Well, of course you
would want to wrap it
with some kind of an
API level because you
want to be able to
consume that service,
and you want to be able to
build mobile apps or web
apps that consume that service.
And the typical
pattern will look
like this, where I have
mobile apps on the left,
they're coming
through the internet.
They're hitting an API.
That API then is the front door
into my service for those apps.
And then the service itself
is doing all the smarts--
it's managing data
with that database,
it's pulling in
third party content,
it's applying business logic
to all of those things.
So pretty standard type
of architecture here
that I'm sure many of you have
built something like this.
But I just want to
recap our requirements.
And particularly when it
comes to a zombie invasion,
our requirements are
very, very important
because we need to be
able to scale our app up
as we need to be
able to scale it up.
The worst thing in the
world is for our app
not to work because of
scale if there really
was a zombie invasion.
And then our customers,
instead of giving us
negative reviews on
our app, are going
to be eaten by these zombies.
So we say, OK, we need
to be able to scale up
and we need to be able
to scale down as needed.
Why do you think one
would want to scale down?
AUDIENCE: Cost.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cost.
Exactly.
A lot of times when
we talk about scale,
we tend to think
in terms of scale
means our app can get
really, really big.
And it can get really,
really big really quickly,
and that's great.
But if you go to a
huge capacity to be
able to handle 10
million concurrent users
or some crazy number like that
and then the zombies are all
gone, and you're paying
for this capacity,
it's not very good
for you as a business.
You want to be able to scale
down very, very quickly.
So we were thinking
we want a technology.
We want to be able
to build this app
so that right now, thankfully,
there are no zombies,
but should they turn up tonight,
that we're going to scale up.
We're going to handle
the capacity of reports
of these zombies,
getting details back
about these zombies so we
can navigate around them.
And then when the
zombies are gone,
we go away from all of that one.
And then, of course,
as I mentioned earlier,
our other requirement-- storing
sensitive business logic data,
such as API keys and that
kind of thing, off the device.
So we started
thinking about this
and how we would build this.
And if you've used
Android Studio,
Android studio has this
handy dandy little tool
for creating cloud
back end modules.
And this is the
wizard on this one.
And what this does is it will
create an App Engine backend,
and it will stub out the
App Engine back for you.
And then it will create
an API level wrapping
that App Engine backend.
So if you remember my
three boxes on my diagram,
this is two of them being
built for me right now.
So this is great.
This is a really,
really good start for me
to be able to do things.
But then there was my data.
So there was that cylinder over
on the right of the diagram.
How do I store my data,
how do I retrieve my data,
and how do I make it scale?
If you guys recognize
this icon, this
is the icon from
Cloud Datastore.
And what Cloud
Datastore gives you
is a NoSQL database that
you can put as the backend.
And as you scale up your
App Engine instances,
it will scale up and
capacity to meet.
And as you scale down, it
will scale down to meet also.
So it seems to be really, really
perfect for our requirements
to use these things.
So let's go back and take a
look at our architecture again.
So here was our architecture--
our mobile device
is on the left, our
API, our service
here, our data on the
backend over on the right.
And then we can say,
OK, with the API
we're using Cloud Endpoints.
Remember that wizard that
I showed you earlier on?
That was the Cloud
Endpoints wizard
that created the API wrapper,
which are the endpoints,
plus the App Engine backend
for me so that I could
write my service in App Engine.
And App Engine runs
Java, Python PHP, Go.
So I could start writing
business logic in these.
Because I did it
in Android Studio,
I wrote my backend for
this application in Java.
And then the database itself
is this NoSQL storage,
so it's the Cloud Datastore.
So it seems like I
have all my pieces here
to be able to scale up
and down as much as I need
to and only pay for the services
that I'm actually using,
which is, particularly
if you're a startup
and you're burning through
seed capital, that's
very, very appealing.
You don't want to budget for
crazy amounts of infrastructure
if you don't need crazy
amounts of infrastructure.
You budget for what you use.
And then, of course,
the last thing for this
was, we said we wanted to
incorporate a third party API.
And in this case,
the third party API
was data coming from Google,
which is that box at the top.
And the data that we use from
Google and we decided to use
was-- you've probably all
seen something like this.
This is a Google map, and
it's showing travel times.
You know those red
blobs around San Mateo
where traffic is much
slower than usual.
The orange blobs is where
it's a bit slower than usual.
Now, this data has to
come from somewhere.
And we said to
ourselves as we're
building this application,
this is great.
So we know we can get this data.
So if there really
is a zombie invasion
and traffic is being
impacted by it,
there's an API
somewhere that we can
call to see if there's
going to be a traffic delay.
And that is API is part of the
Google Maps web services APIs.
Now, there's a whole
bunch of these APIs.
My co speaker was
the expert in these,
and she was going
to talk about them.
Unfortunately, she's not
here, so bear with me.
One of these that I mentioned
was the Directions API
so that you can get turn by
turn directions between A and B.
The one that we're
using in the Zombie Maps
is the Distance Matrix API.
And what that is is you can
feed it a number of sources
and you can feed it a
number of destinations--
excuse the pun about
feeding-- and then
it will tell you all the
different routes between them,
how much it would take.
And then under various
models, like are you walking,
are you driving,
are you flying--
I don't think that's flying--
are you walking, are you
driving, are you busing,
it will tell you the time.
It will also give
you predictive models
based on our knowledge of
the history of these that's
been fed into a machine
learning algorithm
as to say, OK,
usually on a Saturday,
this might be a 20 minute ride.
It's actually going to
be a 25 minute ride.
And that's the perfect
signal for us to say, a ha,
there's a delay here.
Let's see if there's going to
be zombies at that location.
Geocoding, as we can understand,
is typical geocoding.
It's turning numbers
into an actual location--
into an address,
that type of thing.
Places API allows you
to understand places
that you're around.
The Roads API allows you to
snap latitudes and longitudes
to real roads because sometimes
latitudes and longitudes
fed by your phone
are very inaccurate.
Anybody here from
the east coast?
OK.
So on the east coast,
a lot of the highways
have service roads.
And then sometimes when
you're driving on the highway,
your phone thinks, based on
the latitude and longitude,
that you're on that
parallel service road.
That's the kind of
thing I'm talking about.
The Roads API helps you
snap to the real locations.
Elevation, time zone really
speak for themselves.
But these APIs, they give you
the whole world in your hands.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So going back to
our architecture,
here's what we're building.
We really want, then,
the ability for people
to report zombie sightings.
So let's take a look at the
API that we have for that.
So if you've ever built
in Cloud Endpoints before,
you'll build a method into
your business logic tier,
and then you create some
metadata for that method,
and that effectively
turns it into an API.
And here's my API for that.
It's very, very simple.
The yellow tags are
the ones to really take
note of-- the API and
the API namespace.
So once I put them and once
I specify the classes that
are implementing these, then
when I run this on App Engine,
I'm going to get
tools like this.
If you open up your App
Engine app in the browser,
it's just going to
be name.appspot.com.
You can go into the API
explorer from there.
And here, you can see my zombie
reporter API has actually
shown up, just because I put
that metadata into my app
and it was attributing
those classes.
And then you can do things
like testing your API.
I did a test here,
where you can actually
see the URL of my App Engine.
So if you want to try it
out now, you can see it.
And so if I did this,
just to find zombies
and to report the
zombies-- I know
the font is very,
very small here--
but it's just JSON
being returned back.
And the JSON is where somebody
has reported a zombie.
This is the latitude
and longitude
of where it was reported.
And this is the note
associated with it,
like too many to count, they're
breaking out into a dance
party, or some of those things.
So all of these
are built in if I'm
building this an App Engine.
I'm getting these out
of the box for free.
I haven't done anything
other than that attribution
that I just showed.
And now, so when we want
to save our data-- so I've
seen a zombie, I want
to make a report,
and I want to save
it into the database.
This is all I have to do.
This is using a library
called Objectify.
And Objectify, it's
just Java access API
that's been built
for App Engine,
and it's been built
for Cloud Datastore.
And it makes, for me to save
an entity into the database,
as easy as this.
And it's almost just plain
English when you look at it.
It's objectify, save, my
entity-- my entity is called
sighting-- and save it now.
And it's really
as simple as that.
You can learn more about
this library at that link--
github.com/objectify.
I'm building this
logic, and I want
this logic to be able to scale.
I'm building it
into my middleware.
So the next thing
I want it to have
is the location of a zombie.
So this is just a plain old
Java object, as you can see.
It's a public class
zombie location.
I've given it an ID.
I've given it a latitude.
I've given it a longitude.
And it's just a string
for attributing this
that I can give some
details on the zombie
and have some
getters and setters.
But then I just added
these attributes to it.
This is the only
requirement in order
to get the benefit of
Objectify that I've just shown.
Your class, you specify
as an entity in Objectify.
Each of the fields that you want
to store, you put as an index.
The only major
requirement is you
have to have a long called ID,
and you attribute that as ID.
So my plain old Java
object, to turn it
into something that can
be serialized and scaled,
this is all I had to do to it.
Pretty straightforward,
pretty easy, right?
OK, cool.
So now when it comes to storing
this data, and the Objectify
line that I showed
you earlier on,
again, it's just a
straightforward method.
In this case, I call it
insertZombieSighting.
I'm passing a sighting to that.
My API is handling the
transfer over and back
between my Android or iOS
app and the actual backend.
And all that's
going to do is call
that line Objective Save
Entity Sighting Now,
so that I can store my
sighting in the database.
So the next thing is I need
to write something that says,
OK, if I'm going to think
about my business logic,
I'm saying I need to go
from A to B. I've detected
that there's a
delay between here
and there-- I'll show the
code for that in a moment--
and if there's a
delay between here
and there, I need to
present the user to say,
maybe we should find
some zombies between here
and there to see if that's
what's causing our delay.
So here's how I would query
the database to do that.
It's a find zombies method.
And all it is is I'm going
to create an array list
of these zombie location types.
And then in Objectify,
I'm going to load.
And I have to specify the
type that I'm loading in
because earlier when I stored,
they were zombie locations.
So now when I'm
taking them back out,
they're still zombie locations.
And there's only
one constraint when
using this that was a
little bit of a pain,
but it's not too bad.
And that was if I want
to filter on values,
I can only filter
on one value type.
So you can see here, I'm
just filtering on longitude.
So if you think about, I
have a latitude and longitude
for my source.
I have a latitude and
longitude for my destination.
So I said, what I
want to do is I want
to draw a rectangle
around these and find
any zombies within that space.
So I'll start with
the longitudes
and I'll filter
on the longitudes
so I get a filter
of all my zombies
with longitudes that
are within this space.
And then once I
have that in memory,
then I just have
to go through these
and filter them to find
the ones within this space.
So it's a little
bit of a constraint.
I can only filter
on the one field.
But once I've done that,
I have a set in memory,
and it's pretty fast for me
to just iterate through that
and filter out what I need.
And then I get my
collection of zombies,
which I call the Zombies.
And then I return the Zombies.
At this point, I need
to pause for a second.
I've been developing software
for a very, very long time.
And it feels like
my entire career
has built up to this moment
and this line of code.
It is the best line
of code I think
I've ever written in my life,
and it makes me really happy--
just Return theZombies.
[GRR]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So earlier,
I said traffic conditions were
the other thing that we needed.
We needed to consume this third
party for traffic conditions.
And in the geo APIs,
we have this thing
called the Distance Matrix.
So all I have to do to get these
is I use the Distance Matrix
API.
I call the getDistanceMatrix
method on that,
and I pass it a set of origins
and a set of destinations.
In the case of my
app, it's very simple.
I'm having one origin
and one destination.
And then I can specify
different attributes of that,
like my departure
time-- am I leaving now,
am I leaving
tomorrow, those kind
of things, my traffic model.
Just for the sake of
a gratuitous demo,
I decided to make it the
most pessimistic model here.
But there are number ones,
like optimistic, normal,
that type of thing.
The mode-- am I driving,
am I walking, am I biking.
And then I just await
that, await the result.
So I get an
asynchronous callback.
And then once I get
it back, because I
know I've only done one
origin and one destination,
I'm just going to take
out the first element.
The first element of that is
the Distance Matrix element
that I call Item.
And now it's really
nice that I can
start going through
the item, and I
can start querying
properties on that item.
So, for example, things
like the time in traffic.
It's given to me by the API
in human readable form, which
might be 15 minutes.
And it's given to me in
machine readable form, which
is a number, like in seconds.
So this ends up
being really nice.
So then in my business logic, I
can say, the normal time is x,
the current time is y.
But because it's numeric, I
can say, y is greater than x,
then there might be
a zombie invasion.
So here, going back to my
architecture, I've done this.
I have my API.
I've merged this all together.
I've built the service.
I've built the
simple logic into it.
Almost this entire functionality
of giving people the ability
to report a zombie sighting,
giving people the ability
to navigate from A to
B, check the traffic
conditions between
here and B, see
if they are longer
than they should be,
retrieve details of any
zombies between here and B,
and map them all
out-- almost all
that code for that
kind of application,
I've just shown you.
It's a very simple
application, I know,
but when you're thinking about
the amount of functionality
that's in there and
it's done with maybe
30 or 40 lines of code, I
find that really fascinating.
It's not just gratuitous slides.
I actually want to show a demo
and show this thing in action.
So let me switch
to the wolf vision.
And here you can see the
app is actually running.
So on my app, if
I, for example, tap
to report a zombie,
what I've done--
I've hacked this
a little bit, so I
put in a pre-set destination,
and I have a preset source,
and I'm picking a random
latitude and longitude
between them to report it.
In a real app,
you would actually
be just choosing your own
latitude and longitude
for where you're at.
And if I put a note
in here, something
like-- any hockey fans here?
Yay.
San Jose Sharks are
playing tonight.
So I've set this up
for me to navigate down
to the Sharks arena.
But if there's any
zombies on the way,
I'll say something
like, I am not sure
if hockey fans-- whoops, thank
you AutoCorrect-- or zombies.
So I'll put that note in
there, and I will save this.
So I've now reported a zombie.
I have a little
[INAUDIBLE] coming up there
saying that it's done.
So if I hit check traffic
now, my destination
address-- this is the location
where the Sharks actually play.
I'm going to hit
the Search button.
And sometimes when I demo
this, it's really, really slow,
and there's a very
good reason for that.
This time it was really fast.
The reason why it sometimes
is slow when I demo this
is that I'm using App Engine.
And remember I told you it
scales up and scales down
to meet your capacity?
Well, I'm the only person
using this app right now,
so if I hadn't warmed this
up while we were waiting
for the talk to begin,
they'll be no App Engine
instances running.
So I'm not being
charged anything
because I'm not using anything.
But the first time I do it,
it will spin up my first App
Engine.
And then I get charged
for that capacity.
But because I'd warmed up
a little bit earlier on,
that App Engine is up and
running so I'm good to go.
Now we can see here-- I hope you
can see it on the screen, yep--
that it hit a delay.
It's normally 27 minutes from
here to the San Jose Sharks.
It's now estimated 30 minutes.
So shall I check if
there's a zombie invasion?
I think I should.
I'll say yes.
And here we go,
and here's my map.
And it's showing me,
you know, these are
the zombies that were stored.
And if I touch on them,
that's a really big one.
Those ones are ghastly.
And I think that's the
note I made earlier,
I'm not sure if those are
hockey fans or zombies.
So this was just
using the map APIs
that are available for Android.
I just put pins in for those
latitudes and longitudes.
I used a custom
PMG for those pins,
and I attribute them the
way that I had done earlier.
OK, so that's our walking demo.
And here is the application
itself and how it runs.
So what's next?
How would you build
something like this?
Now, hopefully we don't
need to go out and build
zombie detectors.
Thankfully, we don't.
But if you do want
to build something
like this, if you do want
to build something that
uses intelligence-- for example,
about geo data, the way that I
was able to use intelligence
about road services
and how long it's going
to take in traffic
and that kind of thing-- go take
a look at the Google Maps web
services.
They're at this URL.
Cloud Endpoints, which
I used-- in this case--
in Android Studio.
I literally said File, New
Module, Cloud Endpoint.
It gave me a wizard.
And what that does is
that creates an App Engine
instance for you with a
basic API and a basic beam
that you can use to transmit
over and back from that API.
The Cloud Endpoints and Android
Studio, there's a link there.
There's always good stuff on
YouTube.com/GoogleDevelopers
as well.
So yes, and, of course, the
reason why Elena couldn't
be here is she
forgot to use the app
and she got eaten by a zombie.
So just thanks
very much for this.